we here in the basement of the Royal
Society in London the Royal Society is
the UK National Academy of Sciences and
we're here because there's an exhibition
about Rutherford we're interested in the
element rather for diem which is right
here at the bottom of the periodic table
number 104 and with these elements only
tiny amounts relatively few atoms have
been made so we can't tell you about how
it's used in lightbulbs or something
like that because it hasn't been used
for anything people are really excited
if they make just one or two atoms of it
so instead we're going to tell you a bit
about Rutherford after whom it's named
and Rutherford is famous because he did
a whole series of experiments or he and
his coworkers that really explained the
structure of atoms and so the periodic
table for the first time really began to
make sense over here you can see there's
a picture of Rutherford here in his lab
with one of his coworkers
and this is a very famous picture
Rutherford who came from New Zealand had
a very loud voice and the experiments
were rather sensitive if you talk too
loud the apparatus started shaking and
it didn't work properly so his students
put up and big notice in the lab saying
talk softly please but I'm not sure that
it stopped him and I used this picture
when I'm talking to my students about
safety you've always got to be really
safe when you're working as a chemist
first of all you can see that rather
that he's smoking in the lab and then
he's not wearing safety glasses nor is
his colleague and then they have a whole
series of wires and all sorts of things
to trip over so it's really surprising
that they managed to get their
experiments to work without some sort of
serious accident perhaps they did break
things and never told us about it anyway
Rutherford's work was recognized by him
winning the Nobel Prize and here and
that's quite exciting there is a replica
of the Nobel Prize
the Rope Nobel Prize is a gold medal but
here they've shown it as two half medals
underneath you there's nothing to see so
that you can see both of the sides so on
one side there is the portrait of Alfred
Nobel whose money and foundation still
to this day pays for the prize money
when he received this it would have been
presented to him by the swedish king in
a huge ceremony in Stockholm now what I
can't remember is whether he got the
Nobel Prize for physics or chemistry I
have a feeling mystery yes I had the
feeling that he got it for chemistry
which was particularly funny because
Rutherford didn't like chemistry he said
that there's just physics and stamp
collecting and he did not really respect
chemistry so perhaps the chemists got
their revenge by giving him the Nobel
Prize for chemistry Rutherford had very
strong views about the hours his student
should work and they were not allowed to
work after 6 o'clock at night in the lab
and his chief technician would go round
the lab at 6 o'clock and switch off all
the apparatus and chase everybody out of
the lab and even though that they did
this that 11 of his students won Nobel
prizes this must be one of the records
for any single research group to this
day and of course when they went home
having had dinner and drunk wine in the
College then they started working
writing papers but it's very interesting
that if you read letters from visiting
American scientists they couldn't
understand how love Rutherford's lab was
so successful because the people came in
at 10 o'clock in the morning they went
home at 6 and didn't seem to do any work
at all but they discovered all these
wonderful things what's your policy on
your students working
well I always encourage my students to
work but I find that if I encourage them
too hard it has the opposite effect just
like parents telling their children to
do their homework but by and large when
people are enthusiastic about their
science it's difficult to stop them
working too much
as part of this exhibition they've got
some postcards of Rutherford and this
one shows Brett I think's really
terrific Rutherford in the sea but I
really like this because it shows that
famous scientists sometimes take time
off and they don't always behave like
white coated figures in lamps but they
do have a human side as well